as is so often the case the disaster
makes headlines and the recovery very
quickly falls out of the news cycle and
sadly massive parts of Puerto Rico are
still lacking electricity they had this
deadline of getting back to 95% power
restoration by now and they're only at
64% power restored which is really
really bad why don't they have more
power in Puerto Rico according to the
union president for the employees at the
Power Company they don't have enough
equipment or materials to get power
turned back on and reportedly there are
Puerto Rican residents remember the
island has been economically in rough
shape for years it's particularly
ravaged now because of the Hurricanes
there are Porto Rican residents
personally buying supplies for the
workers horrible 78 municipalities in
Puerto Rico nine of them still have zero
percent power no power at all meaning
that there's not even a place nearby to
go and charge your phone without leaving
your municipality the new goal is to
have at least one part of each of the 78
municipalities with some power by
Christmas which is very very soon and
part of this is reportedly the federal
government being slow to get them what
they need the federal government is
depends who you ask but the
administration the White House is
pointing to Congress not having
appropriated enough funds that they're
waiting on Congress and also there are
some sort of infrastructure complexities
in Puerto Rico for example a lot of the
electrical lines and the electrical
poles in Puerto Rico are on top of
buildings so instead of having a ground
pole that you can just climb to work on
you need to get access through the
building in order to actually get on top
of that pole that's going to expand the
amount of time it takes significantly
and speaking of forgetting about the
recovery it'd be wrong for me to only
talk about Puerto Rico the Virgin
Islands are still having major issues
restoring power depending on which
island and area you look at the islands
have parts where only half of the Power
has been restored
certainly more in some other areas and
it's just so pathetic because you know
that if
we were invading Puerto Rico our
military would have had power
established everywhere that it was
needed in a fraction of the time and
that relates the budget priorities right
the amount we spend on defense and the
military even on weapons we will never
use dwarfs the money that we are even
hypothetically willing to spend on
getting power back up in Puerto Rico
never mind what we're actually spending
now disgusting and embarrassing yeah we
really have to keep the focus on this
because there's so much attention to it
once it happens right once the natural
disaster occurs of course people give
money to the Red Cross and help in any
way that they can but then a few months
down the road people lose interest and
stop caring so think about California
wildfires right what you see is the
horrific images that of the inferno that
it becomes when they have these
wildfires but then after a few weeks you
never hear anything about the recovery
people who have lost their houses all of
that so we're gonna try to keep the
focus on it and right now not looking
good not looking good in Puerto Rico